Every day, an incredible amount of life
passes over our heads
we can see things like birds and bats,
but there’s an even
larger number of bugs
researchers in England used
an upward-pointing radar beam
to quantify just how many
smaller insects were
also collected in nets
hung from a blimp
Using radar, they could track the size of
insects
as well as their speed and direction
this study tracked many kinds of insects
over a 10 year period
to find broad patterns
Surprisingly many insects migrated north and
south with the seasons, just like birds
seasonal migration was thought to be rare
among insects,
but it actually seems that
many large insects do it,
meaning they must have a
very good sense of direction
insects flying at great heights outweigh
migrating birds in the same region
by a factor of 8
The researchers estimate more than three trillion bugs
fly over southern England each year
-- that’s about 3200 tons--
or 20,000 reindeer